[Music]
foreign
CBS deals this morning we have several
items that might help you relax and
recharge over the weekend whether you're
just chilling at home or having friends
over for a game day and all these
products are at exclusive low prices to
start shopping now you can scan the QR
code on your screen or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert sukanya
Christian joins us with more good
morning nice to see you Jeff and boy do
we have a lot of things for you I don't
know do you have back pain or do you
know people with back I've had back
surgery oh you've had back surgery so
I've got the perfect thing for you this
is called the calming heat back wrap and
take a look at this it's an actual
portable back wrap that you can put on
and you can be on the go with this so
you just basically put the velcro on
it's got different uh variations of
therapeutic massage heat and also lumbar
support and what I love about this is
that you can actually take it on the go
so if you need to go to the office you
can use that and and it's portable yeah
exactly right and that is 50 51.99 yeah
the deal is absolutely fantastic we're
looking at a discount of up to 35
percent and we're looking at 51.99 go to
cbsdeals.com this is great for somebody
who's an athlete for somebody who's just
suffering with back pain a little bit
different of a category but these is
it's not oh this is opo Pop opal pop
okay it is the popcorn Revolution and
I've popped some popcorn for you and
what it has is this technology that
actually puts the flavor into the kernel
and you're thinking how do they do that
I don't know I can answer that question
but they did it it's a revolution when
it comes to popcorn and a revolution of
flavor so Jeff we've got two different
packages for our CBS viewers so you've
got a game Day package and you also have
a family package and it starts at 33.50
all the way to 55.99 and you got a
savings of 26 you want to try something
I see vanilla cake pops andalicious yeah
keep going I have a Pinot salted Umami
and I like Maui heat in fact my kids had
this as a snack on the way home three
minutes keeps the kids Happy keep you
full and it's a great snack on the go
all right next okay run run right now to
cbsdeals.com because the last time this
was on it actually sold out so this is
called The Rush charge and you're
thinking to yourself what is the rush
charge it has actually three different
charging outputs right here so you can
put three different devices it's on the
go it comes fully charged so you open it
up out of the package and it goes and
what I love about it look at the video
of the woman actually using the phone
and charging her phone at the same time
and how many times have we been caught
without a fully charged phone or a fully
charged device and it seems like I'm
that person as well my child has used
this he's had his laptop not charged I
don't get emails from the teacher
anymore thanks to rush charge
everybody's always looking for sure this
one a discounted 21 exactly discounted
21 we're looking at an exclusive deal at
54.99 head on over to cbsdeals.com I'm
telling you we're going to hook you up
very nice sukanya thank you very much
thank you very much Jeff we partner with
all these companies to get you these
deals to buy anything you saw today
again scan the QR code on your screen or
head over to cbsdeals.com